girl power sales fashion and juicy love
stores so your things then I need you to
get on board
TV lands and younger season six just
familiar this week but don't worry there
is time to catch up here's why it makes
ETS been worthy watchlist I'm gonna be a
dad oh we drop bombs at the end of every
episode so you're kind of like I'm so
short I know I need another it's like a
I don't know like a potato chip you know
it goes down so easy and you always want
more 22 minutes of just pure joy yeah
once you start binging just can't stop
the good news it will only take 22 hours
to get through the first five seasons oh
you got yourself into a pickle Sutton
Foster is Liza a 40-something mom
pretending to be in her 20s to keep her
job in publishing
Hilary Duff plays her bestie and while
we love how these ladies are all about
empowering each other it's hard not to
covet their killer closets
now Kelsey's sharing an apartment with
three people and a baby but I'm wearing
Gucci verbal grenade and ran another
reason to watch the show is from the
creator of Sex in the City
so yeah there is a lot of relationship
drama at the center of it all is Liza's
love triangle and even the cast is
divided between two Charles and team
Josh the odd is alive as you are with
Josh and different whatever I get to
have my own view and a potato your
absolute I'm like one of the only ones
that feels this way know one thing
everyone can agree on the men of younger
are easy guys that's a lot to wrap my
head around when he arrived on set by
the first day of shooting someone said
Charles right and I thought they were
burning the character so I answered and
they answered no no hot Charles I mean
it's kind of a diss the Charles is hot
the under airs the Wednesday night
everywhere
[Music]